the reasons why I'm the American public
over a long span of time 100 150 200
years has been mostly disinterested or
at least only casually interested in
what's going on in the rest of the world
is that we were developing a whole
continent here we had our own major
mission which was manifest destiny to
the other coast we had two huge oceans
on either side of us and up to our north
we had a very benign neighbor and to our
south while there are emigration
problems and so on but my national
security point of view that has been
very benign so there were far fewer
reasons why we would be engaged than if
you lived in a smaller country in Europe
where they were always in conflict over
one thing or another for hundreds and
hundreds of years 9/11 did indeed change
this because it is the first time since
the war of 1812 that the United States
actually had foreign hostile activity
within its own borders and what 9/11 did
among many other things is to suddenly
make the American public aware that in
the modern world of mobile of
globalization both of security weaponry
as well as economics and culture was no
longer sort of invulnerable to the to
the plights and the conflicts and the
tensions and the angers elsewhere in the
world that those oceans those two benign
north and south borders were only in our
smaller part of the story so that did
indeed create a greater interest but
primarily the American public's
interests in foreign affairs waxes and
wanes dependent on how much they think a
crisis is about to affect us at home
during the Cold War years of 50 years or
so of the Cold War the atomic the
bulletin of the atomic science used to
have a clock and they would show the
second hand getting a first hand getting
close to him closer to midnight whenever
the Soviet Union
States got into a first class class
clash the biggest one being of course
over Cuba every time that happened the
interest in international affairs zoomed
to the top as soon as things calm down
again it disappeared again and they
worried about local problems and so on
the same thing to a certain extent has
happened since 9/11 there is not the
same level of acute interest now that
there was then but globalization has
also meant there other wait reasons to
be interested in what's going on in the
world besides the security questions
there's the prosperity of the country
which now is dependent on the highly
internationalized economic system so I
think we're better off than we were and
when polls are taken four key things
like do you think the UN is a necessary
institution and set of processes the
answer invariably is yes it's a
reluctant answer they wish it wasn't so
they're not enthusiastic and they know
all the problems of the UN but they
don't
Madonn take an isolationist position
that we would be better off without it
some politicians from usually the
extremes of one party or another still
try to sell the idea that fortress
America would work just have a strong
military a strong economy stayed out of
everybody else's business and would be
okay that is not an opinion that then
any more captures in large public they
don't believe it's realistic they don't
believe that you can have a prosperous
America a safe America just by staying
within some sort of Continental fortress
so to speak